on vous a dévoilé le menu de
l'incroyable dîner le dîner donc était
très bon mais dis-moi est-ce que donc
tout le monde a bon à manger Dieu
bénisse bien tout ça il paraît que tout
le monde a mangé quant à manger quoi
là-bas rien du tout même pas de
bouteille d'eau quoi
tu es rentré comment RER très à pied
non c'était une rage je suis resté très
très longtemps ah oui
Charles il t'a pas vu ça bah non Charles
m'a pas vu moi je l'ai vu comme ça voilà
mais lui il m'a pas vu alors tu étais
content quand même oui je suis quand
même alors on vous a dévoilé le menu de
l'incroyable dîner organisé par Emmanuel
Macron hier soir aujourd'hui on va
parler du vin puisque les 160 convives
du dîner 150 qui en a dit ce qui ont
planté ont pu déguster les vins
d'exception dont un à plus de 2772 euros
la bouteille
2800 balles la bouteille alors il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont dit c'est une
admissible c'est le débat du jour
dites-nous ce que vous en pensez est-ce
que c'est indécent c'est parti regarder
depuis hier
c'est les trois
nous pouvons compter sur notre solide
amitié avec son épouse ils ont tout un
programme à suivre
en soirée ils étaient au château de
Versailles avec le couple
m'a quitté trié sur le bolet autour d'un
dîner prestigieux et d'une table de 62
mètres de long en entrée un arbre bleu
en plus du homard bleu de la volaille de
Brest du fromage et des macarons des
bouteilles de vin d'exception leur ont
été servis une aberration pour certaines
personnes bah ouais ça a quelque chose
d'indécent de voir les gens faire ça
alors des bouteilles de vin 27
60 invités lors du dîner en l'honneur du
roi Charles III est un descend
[Musique]
ça descend qui trouve ça descend
Géraldine non absolument aucune
indécence moi je trouve que c'est
indécent trouver c'est indécent ça fait
partie du prestige de la vitrine de
l'entente cordiale en fait je pense que
ceux qui disent oui auraient voulu qu'on
reçoive le roi Charles avec je sais pas
de la villageoise un taboulé des
couverts en carton en fait elle a aucun
sens en fait c'est en plus ces
bouteilles ont été offertes par les
viticulteurs de Bordeaux l'édition et le
millésime 2004 symboliquement c'était
fort parce que le millésime change
d'étiquette tous les ans et 2004 c'est
une aquarelle qui a peint Le Roi Charles
c'était un très beau symbole et un très
beau geste aussi donc en fait voilà il y
a c'est circuler il y a rien à voir à
part les insoumis qui évidemment vont
trouver que c'est c'est c'est des bagues
enfin voilà par démagogie ouais voilà
par exemple mais visiblement Raymond
aussi donc
moi tu peux être surpris mais ça c'est
tout le bordel moi qui me qui me dérange
la bouteille on ne me dis pas est-ce que
le bordel vous avez la question tout le
bordel me gêne parce que c'est la
période qui va pas tout le bordel me
gêne la bouteille elle me dérange le
repas à 2007 me dérange qu'on est bloqué
Paris toute une journée ça me dérange
parce que quand c'est pour faire des
manifs pour les grèves et des manifs
pour les gilets jaunes tous les
commerçants vend debout on nous a bloqué
tout le quartier là on a pas attendu un
commerçant de dire on est en train de
créer un commerçants
qu'on a pas réussi à vendre des slips
qu'on a pas réussi à vendre des chemises
pas un commerçant à brancher la semaine
dernière on m'explique que le pape il
est à Marseille 5000 policiers qui sont
des beaux qui sont débauchés ça gêne
personne donc quand on peut le faire moi
je dis qu'une bouteille de vin 2700
balles dans la situation on est
aujourd'hui avec les Français qu'on nous
explique tous les soirs que les Français
soufflent l'électricité un plan
d'essence pas en dessous de 100 euros en
plein essence vous ça c'est pas grave ça
concerne ça c'est pas des magot c'est la
vie des Français un français il peut pas
regarder sa télé ce soir ils ont mis
2007 ils ont acheté 10 15 bouteilles de
vin ils ont été à Versailles tout le
monde est venu you grand 160 bouteilles
mais tu crois que 160 x 2007 et après on
vient m'expliquer qu'il y a plus
d'argent et que l'électricité va
augmenter encore de 10% que l'essence va
rester à plus de 2 € qu'on est en train
de réduire les pâtes à 500 g pour pour
justement
tout ce que je viens de dire tu ne le
fais pas l'essence ça te regarde pas
ma vie tu habites à Paris tous les jours
toi moi je prends pas le métro je fais
50 bornes
si tu veux 400 € toujours la vie
c'est pas le fait qu'on propose mais de
laisse un peu les gens parler moi c'est
pas c'est pas le nom de la vie des
Français alors franchement c'est bon on
a compris on a compris ton message
et après j'en ai pas pour longtemps
c'est pas le fait qu'on propose le
meilleur au roi c'est normal qu'on
propose le meilleur de ce que fait la
France au roi c'est qui est 180
personnes qui sont toutes là autour
d'une table on dirait que la photo a été
prise il y a 400 ans et tous ces gens-là
moi là ça fait chier que tous ces
gens-là ils sont en train de boire du
vin qui coûte aussi cher parce que là
content devient complètement pourquoi
parce que les gammaité des invitants
qu'est-ce qu'on s'en fout des invités
du tout alors moi j'aimerais avoir
Jacques Cardot je pense que là vous êtes
totalement il y a plein de
téléspectateurs qui vivent ils allaient
pas boire de la piquette
pardon à moi vraiment je t'adore mais là
vous êtes totalement à côté de la plaque
c'est une opération de communication et
de vente du pays à travers le monde
c'est si cette opération est réussie
attend laisse-moi terminé tu as été long
c'est grâce à ça qu'on aura des
touristes chinois des touristes
américains des touristes ceux-ci ceux-là
ils viendront hiver on Versailles ils
s'intéresseront à la bouteille qui a été
vendu etc ça nous coûte quoi au regard
de ce que ça peut nous rapporter
une opération de communication et de il
s'agit du prestige de la France c'est
des images qui font rêver à travers le
monde s'en fout mais pas du tout
les gens c'est dans toute la presse
people et en Angleterre tu vois la
France Paris ça fait déjà les Anglais
ils viendront à Versailles parce que
Versailles ça fait rêver et puis voilà
c'est comme ça et c'est grâce à ça qu'on
aura de l'argent parce que vous avez
oublié de dire je le tourisme ça
rapporte beaucoup et c'est même la seule
chose qui rapporte énormément en France
Jacques cardeau de là vous êtes et vous
voyez pas vous voyez pas plus loin là tu
vas continuer là tu vois pas plus loin
il s'agit de payer ton 750 € à double
magnum de Mouton Rothschild 2015 vous
êtes malade mais c'est 0,01 %, vous êtes
on regarde tout ce que ça va rapporter
pour le pays est-ce que ça va le
tourisme rapport c'est ce qui paiera
c'est ce qui peut rater
150 privilégiés qui se sont gavés ça
coûte une Afrique fou tout va se
déployer pour le droit d'Angleterre
on est des mots en démocratie on s'en
fout Siri il faut faire rêver les gens
les gens ils ont besoin de le prix que
ça coûte cet argent là il fallait mettre
dans les services publics par
l'éducation
avec les ineptiques tu dis arrête de
dire les conneries
2800 balles pour un double Magnum mais
c'est honteux que tu voulais l'inviter
comme
doberman mais tu as des couilles de
chihuahua
[Applaudissements]
ce que tu racontes une seule bêtise que
franchement je regrette presque d'avoir
traversé la France pour ce genre de
chose tu aurais voulu qu'ils partent en
vie trône qui mange à hot-dog avec du
Boulaouane
c'est la France et le prestige la France
ou alors soit dans les jours de
Versailles c'est pas moi le 22 septembre
il y a plein de Français qui l'achètent
tous les jours je dis pas il travaille
moins et Raymond toi je t'ai vu tu as
dépensé plus que 2007
à Saint-Tropez
Jean-Michel c'est pas c'est notre argent
mais quand on aime le ballon c'est aussi
qu'il y a des petits producteurs qui
font un très bon vin
c'est vrai la réalité
en Allemagne il y a quelques temps en
Allemagne c'était pas le même protocole
c'était quelque chose de beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus simple mais ça va les
Allemands c'est pas non plus la dernière
roue du carrosse de l'Europe ils savent
quand même recevoir le roi le roi c'est
très récent et avec plus de dignité les
Allemands ils t'ont bien reçu le roi je
sais pourquoi c'est le Mouton Rothschild
parce que le Mouton Rothschild à travers
le monde tout le monde sait ce que ça
veut dire et donc cette bouteille là
elle sera achetée et c'est tu sais que
le l'alcool c'est quelque chose qu'on
exporte énormément et grâce à ça
et les Français qui traitent
commerciale de la France c'est grâce aux
vins que que mes convent réussi à vendre
à l'étranger enfin c'est les alcools qui
marchent le mieux et le luxe qui marche
déjà
cette soirée-là c'est le luxe et le vin
et c'est ce qu'on vend le mieux
historique de Hugo pardon Hugo mais on
peut pas comparer les relations entre la
France et la entre l'Angleterre et
l'Allemagne et l'Angleterre et la France
je te rappelle quand même on doit à
l'Angleterre enfin on a quand même
organisé notre résistance et le général
de Gaulois organisé la résistance en
Angleterre donc on a une relation qui
est privilégiée avec l'Angleterre et ça
n'est pas la même chose
Géraldine mais ça n'empêche que c'est
une visite d'État et j'ai jamais dit que
le relation entre l'Angleterre et la
France c'était la même qu'entre la
manière alors moi j'ai juste envie de
reprendre l'argumentaire de Raymond on
s'en souvient tous puisqu'il a très bien
parler et j'ai envie de dire comme
d'habitude bravo
[Applaudissements]
il aurait pu y avoir un juste milieu et
aujourd'hui au regard de ce qui se passe
en
France et on en parle tous les soirs ici
on ne peut pas voir ça moi j'ai
l'impression effectivement j'ai
l'impression d'être en France pendant la
monarchie avec voilà avec avec la
royauté et nous le petit peuple qui
galérons et ça me dérange vraiment
à faire boire du groupe plan et manger
je pense que Versailles c'est notre
image à travers le monde moi je suis
d'accord avec ce qu'a dit Jacques c'est
à dire qu'on peut pas recevoir le roi
c'est une question d'honneur français et
on met en avant notre production donc
tant mieux pour pour le business et les
emplois que ça peut créer derrière et
l'image de la France le luxe c'est ce
qui nous porte LVMH c'est le fleuron à
l'étranger on est connu pour ça si on
peut pas recevoir les gens à l'Élysée à
effectivement des vêtements qu'il faut
derrière il y a des emplois
combien de produits du vin il y a des
milliers d'emplois et même des des
petites mains enfin
qui paye tout ça le homard et tout qui
le paye justement qui le paye mais tu
crois
chaque année il y a un budget sur les
réceptions c'est moi je préfère qu'on
mette ce budget pour le mettre sur les
écoles
je pense que c'est juste moralement pas
le moment donc c'est vrai qu'entre 2700
et une grosse piquette bien sûr on
reçoit pas le roi comme ça mais va dire
au type qui est là à la mer célibataire
qui finit pas son moi le 5 et qui a sec
d'ailleurs eux ils étaient pas assez ils
ont bu une à Magnum à 2007 c'est
inaudible c'est inaudible qu'est-ce que
tu en penses toi ce n'est pas l'argent
du contribuable vous avez l'argent
c'est inaudible il faut l'expliquer je
vous ai dit 250 journalistes à crudité
dont la moitié des internationaux qui
vont faire des qui vont faire des
articles
d'acheter des espaces des gens dans la
rue les gens qui vivent les Français
c'est pas audible et je pense que la
France a des temps elle est vous êtes
demandeur pour l'instant
national de Canada est accrédité
l'Australie est accrédité puisque ça
fait partie des pays du Commonwealths
du monde de rugby ce voyage en ligne de
mire les Jeux Olympiques on va vendre
ton camion de la réalité c'est que c'est
des infos c'est de l'argent pour la
France je vais dire quelque chose
magnifique parce que c'est une année
formidable parce que la France n'a pas
les épaules d'organiser tout et bien sûr
si on n'est pas en France actuellement
ouais moi je pense qu'on est beaucoup
moins ce qui compte c'est ce que les
gens est-ce que les gens sont heureux ou
pas là j'ai l'impression que non moi
personnellement exactement voilà Raymond
tu vas finir en fait il y aura plus de
composition
je vous dis juste qu'il faut faire
attention avec le message envoyé oh hier
on a un économiste qui est venu qui nous
parlait des des fruits et légumes de
Leclerc comment il s'appelle
attention à la colère des Français
faites attention parce que c'est ce
qu'on redoute le plus ils nous l'ont dit
et là qu'est-ce que vous faites vous
allez c'est bon il y a pas de problème
et j'entends Jacques que moi j'aime
beaucoup aussi Jacques mais quand il dit
son movie l'année extraordinaire alors
où tu vis une chance je vais venir avec
toi parce que moi nous on a de la chance
on vit une annexe extraordinaire on est
content on se plaint pas mais va va
parler avec les gens viens avec moi
tourner une matinée tu vois je suis pas
conscient de la galère dans laquelle
sont les gens mais si on extraordinaire
on devait tuer Poutine en trois mois en
3 mois Poutine il devait sortir de la
liste il devait partir de son pays et
tout allait bien vous allez voir euh
McDonald's est parti de la Russie c'est
fini Poutine il va rendre les arbres il
a jamais le dossier riche Poutine mais
je veux pas te présenter nulle part
j'explique juste que c'est pas c'est pas
un combat et c'est pas une bonne idée
non plus je suis d'accord avec Hugo
c'est pas entendre de vous voir dire oh
2007 c'est normal on a fermé Paris
pendant une journée entière c'est normal
les commerçants ils ont pas pu
travailler c'est normal on a fait chier
les Français c'est normal parce que il y
a le prince Charles je vais te dire par
là que les gens parlez avec les gens du
roi Charles là parleur dans la rue et
ils vont te dire j'en ai rien à [__]
tout le reste d'accord
[Applaudissements]
mais mais les gars moi je vois mes potes
arrêtez je vois mes potes j'ai des j'ai
des dizaines de potes toute la journée
ils en ont rien à carrer du roi Charles
ce qu'ils veulent ce qu'ils veulent
c'est pouvoir kiffer la vie et pouvoir
gagner l'oseille et pouvoir vivre mes
pouvoirs manger tu crois que la vie du
roi Charles qui boit qui boit des
bouteilles à 2800 balles ils en ont rien
à carrer tu sais quoi ils sont fous de
Total et je suis d'accord avec Clément
qui doit parler avec les mêmes gens que
moi toute la journée et il y en a un qui
t'a dit ouais tout le monde quand tu
parles tu vas dans les bistrots
et si je dis l'argument de Jacques où
même tu veux dire
les petits commerçants ce qui s'est
passé avec le touriste cet été tu veux
que je te dis ce qui s'est passé
raconte-nous
les mecs ils étaient vraiment ils ont
pas compris cette année ce qui s'est
passé
il y a eu un drame qui s'est passé à la
défense avec un petit et il y a eu des
émeutes tu sais tous les gens qui ont de
l'argent là tous les gens que vous dites
ils vont venir ils vont acheter des sacs
ils sont pas venus à Paris ils ont eu
peur ils sont pas venus à Paris tu les
as les chiffres du tourisme tu les as tu
les as ils vont sortir bientôt moi je
les ai déjà parce que les gens dans les
restaurants et dans les bas dans les
magasins dans les boutiques ils m'ont
dit il y a pas de tourisme les touristes
qui avaient de l'argent ils ont eu peur
des émeutes sont pas venus c'est bien
beau de dire ici
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous dire
la France est une catastrophe non non
parce que là il dit qu'il y a moyen de
la France tous les gens et le tourisme
écoutez-moi bien écoutez moi bien je
vais vous dire ce qui se passe avec la
France il y a un truc qui a été qui est
vraiment symptomatique c'est c'est
simple il y a eu la finale de la Coupe
du Monde France - Argentine tout le
monde n'était pas un mec qui était pour
la France dans le monde entier tous les
pays étaient pour l'Argentine parce que
ils aient voilà la France on passe pour
voilà je vous le dis on est depuis
quelques temps
tous les pays du Maghreb ils étaient
pour l'Argentine
et pour l'Angleterre ce n'est pas
l'Allemagne
c'est symptomatique toute l'Afrique
était pour l'Argentine tout le monde
voulait que la France perdent c'est
grave ou pas bah ça pour moi c'est ça
pour moi c'est symptomatique ça veut
tout dire voilà ils disent voilà on en a
marre des donneurs de leçons là qui
veulent des données des leçons à tout le
monde et qui qui voilà et c'est quoi et
qui donne des leçons à personne bon
tiens bah justement là on voit le
franchement la transition est parfaite